what if I told you that every time
you're asleep in your bed at night your
private thoughts might be compromised
what if when you're dreaming about all
your hopes fears and ideas a cerebral
security breach could lead to the
ultimate psychological heist that's
right your dreams are about to be hacked
what powers with these dream hackers
possess and how would it change our
society this is what if and here's what
would happen if your dreams could be
hacked
dreams are extremely valuable they
generate ideas inspiration help us solve
problems and much more but despite their
importance scientists still aren't sure
why we dream we have several theories
like dreams are a way to process
emotions express our desires and gain
real-life practice when confronted with
potential dangers other theories suggest
that dreaming has no real purpose at all
either way there's still something going
on inside your head you and the rest of
the human population spend about six
years of your life dreaming in REM sleep
and it's more if you include dreams in
the other sleep stages that's a lot of
information that's just there for the
taking what if a shadowy group and the
ability to extract those private little
thoughts from that head of yours what
kind of information could they extract
governments could spy on their citizens
making sure no one is planning an
uprising industry saboteurs could spy on
competitors technology by entering their
workers dreams the police could try to
identify murderers or solve other crimes
by entering suspects dreams and what
about those questionable dreams you
don't want to tell anybody about do
clams develop go yes every awkward dream
could be exposed and used against you
potentially even to prosecute you think
you could dream up a lawyer
and that's just if these dream hackers
are taking information what if they left
some behind this planted info could be
anything from companies filling your
dreams with advertisements to other
people manipulating your emotions to how
you perceive the world you could wake up
one day and hate all your left ones and
not even remember why or on the flip
side you could wake up with a yearning
desire for the mailman nothing what's
been that cute
so with those dream hackers out there
how would you sleep at night
well if people knew their dreams could
be breached they would try to stop
dreaming altogether people might try to
take dream suppressing drugs to lock
down their slumbering state and people
who couldn't afford the drugs would be
chugging coffee and fighting off sleep
as if Freddy Krueger was about to show
up so could you prepare for the upcoming
dream invasion could you hack into your
own dreams and set up a mental firewall
well there is something called dream
incubation which happens when you plant
a seed for a specific dream to occur
this method is often used when people
want to solve a problem while they sleep
you should start thinking about all the
locked doors and security systems you
can
steal your mind oh hey I was just
dreaming of a great new way to share
videos on your phone but turns out it's
real in these weird times of social
distancing and isolation along comes
something that really connects us you
know necessity is the mother of
invention and we're spending way more
time with our phones connecting with our
friends through social media and
watching videos so it was only natural
that the mother of invention would have
another child and she named it sniffle
sniffle creates a whole new category
premium social video it's the beginning
of a new movement called video socialism
it connects you with your friends and
family and lets you watch and share
amazing videos of all kinds music movie
trailers gaming fashion sports news all
in one place and you can invite up to
four friends to watch videos together in
real time and comment on them in real
time too it's pretty amazing you got to
try it out sniffle is built for all of
us to stay connected and enjoy the best
videos in these isolated times social
video is here to stay and it's free not
a dream
real go to the Apple Store to download
when asleep we dream about every 90
minutes so you need to give yourself
time to experience it about 7 to 8 hours
of sleep is needed and most importantly
encourage yourself to remember the
security you added when you wake up
because if you don't we'll have to start
again
but this is just science fiction right
well since the year 2017 mit has been
running a dream lab here a group of
researchers is developing a technology
capable of mining the subconscious
their current pride and joy is a device
called der mio which tracks Aware's
muscle tone heart rate and skin
conductance feeding audio cues at
certain stages of sleep that then
becomes part of the wearer's dreams
since researchers are already able to
influence the dream and extract some
information dream hacks could really
happen all we're waiting for our smaller
devices that can be applied undetected
and without a person's knowledge or
consent it might be a good idea to start
taking control of your dreams right now
that way when the dream hackers come for
you you'll be ready but what if we were
able to remove the problem entirely and
took away the cache of valuable dreams
what if we no longer needed sleep well
that's a story for another what if
[Music]